وللويات بطولات ومنافسات وكاس عالمي يحتفي
بمحترفين فبعد تحقيقه المركز الثاني في
اخر نسخه فاز الفريق الياباني اخيرا بكاس
العالم للحلويات التي تقام كل سنتين في
اليوم الفرنسيه توج اليابانيون يوم السبت
بعد منافسه مع 17 فريقا من جميع انحاء
العالم يضم كلا من صانع لشكلته وخبير سكر
وصانع ايس كريم المسابقه بدات المره
الاولى عام 99
وفرنسا تتصدر بعشره ميداليات من ضمنها
زمان ميداليه الذهبيه واليابان بعد الفوز
الاخير فقط الى المركز الثاني برصيد ثلاث
ميداليات ذهبيه وازاحه ايطاليا التي اصبحت
ثالثا فازت اليابان في نسختي 1991 و2007
وفي نسخه العام حققه الميداليه الذهبيه
بعد صنع حلوى تحمل عنوان الرياح والخفه
متى بدا الحلويات اللبنانيه على الاغلب من
مكونات طبيعيه وموجوده في اليابان على عكس
الحلويات الغربيه التي تعتمد على مجموعه
واسعه من المكونات من حول
العالم تعتمد يابان على بعض من ثمارها
لصنع الحلوى ابرزها الخوخ والبرقوق بدلا
عن السكر كما يعتبر الارز مكون مهم في عدد
من الحلويات اهمه هاموتشي احد اهم ممثلين
ومطبخ الحلوى الياباني مربى الفاصوليا
انكو هي عجينه تصنع من فصول الازوكي
المسلوقه ومكون اساسي من حشو العديد من
الحلويات اليابانيه والعشي من الحلويات
التقليديه الشهيره التي تدخل الفاصولياء
الاوزوكي في تحريرها وتتميز بتصاميمها
المختلفه في موسم الربيع مثلا تاخذ شكل
اشجار الكرز او ما يعرف باسم ساكورا ويتم
تقديمها مع الشاي
شاي الماتش الشهير ليس شرابا فقط بل مكون
شائع في الحلويات ايضا يستخدم في تحضير
الكعك والحلويات وهو ايضا نكهه ايس كريم
متداوله
[موسيقى]
تنضمي الي انا رومي اهلا بك معنا رومي
مديره مطعم حلويات يابانيه اهلا
[موسيقى]
مبروك الفوز بالميداليه الذهبيه لليابان
في كاس العالم للحلويات وحدثين ما الذي
يميز الحلويات اليابانيه التي تتوج بهذه
الجائزه القيمه في فرنسا
جوال في الواقع كما استخدمت معي هنا انا
كعكه الجبنه الشهيره باتت من اشهر الكعكات
والحلويات في العالم حاليا وهناك الامور
الكثيره التي بدات تتصدر الاهتمامات في
العالم في الحقيقه الحلويات جزء من تاريخ
المطبخ الياباني وهذا بدا شيء معروف والان
شهرت هذا المطبخ وشهره الحلويات تزداد هنا
في المنطقه ولكن في كل انحاء العالم وانا
اتيت بهذه
المحلويات من متجرنا اليكم
اه
ولكن
معروف جدا
مقارنه بباقي الحلويات العالميه التي
تحتوي على الكثير من المكونات
[موسيقى]
ليست حلوه كثيرا ولكن في نفس الوقت يشعرون
بالامتنان وبذنب اقل لان السكر اقل اذا
هناك
بدنا رومي الي اي حد تعكس الحلويات
اليابانيه الثقافه اليابانيه من التصميم
من المكونات من الحشوه ما لها ذلك
استنتاج واقعي جدا
ان الموضوع يتعلق بالبساطه كما في كل شيء
في اليابان يتعلق الامر بالطحين بالسكر
بالبيض وهناك جزء كبير من تاريخ اليابان
في الطعام مبني على هذه البساطه ولكن هذا
المطبخ يعود لا 400 عاما على الاقل
بما انه بدنا نومي جايبه معها يعني تشكيله
هيك بسيطه وخفيفه بالنسبه للحلويات تشرح
لنا تعطينا شو اسم كل نوع لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
سوا سوا
او الكريب او فطائر البان كيك المعروفه
الامريكيه
بالنسخه اليابانيه
انها محشوه بعجينه الفاصوليا مع الزبده
والقطعه الاخرى هي الكستله وهي نوع من
الكعكه الاسفنجيه اليابانيه وهي شهيره
ايضا وهي من ان اقدم
اقدم الحلويات وعمرها 400 عام هذه الكعكه
الاسفنجيه
كانت الماتشا وهي مصنوعه من مسحوق الشاي
الاخضر وهذه القطعه تعرف بموتشي وهي بتتت
معروفه وهي من اقدم الحلويات اليابانيه
تصنع من الارز المطحون
ولكن
البيضاء
وهي التقليديه ولكن اليوم الكثير من
الاشخاص لا يحبين الحشوه الفاصولياء
الحلوه والتالي يتم حشو هذه الحلويات
الشهيره
[موسيقى]